[Music]
this is a
warning doing so could result in a
terrible disaster
do not change
[Music]
this is cryptic case
you're a detective trying to solve what
keyboard is this why are there so many
shift buttons across the keyboard this
does it
yeah whatever it's fine new game
there's another mystery to solve here
besides that keyboard some kind of a
murder i'm guessing
some kind of a problematic death dealing
working over time again
i swear i'm the only one who does
anything around here
hmm still i suppose little extra labor
won't kill me
yeah i suppose not
maybe you're wrong
[Music]
who is this
you don't know me emmett
but i know you
eight
11
94.
do you
remember
oh
hey did you
did you just
did you just what finish your thought
do i have a fly dude
okay
well a little extra labor won't kill me
this is weird to have framed on the wall
like i just want to point that out
unless that's just an art piece
and not an actual crime scene i'm gonna
be a little concerned
detective proof crime detective theft
murder searching detective
missing i love a good red string board
i love it three one one
371 g
138 fl question question 9 place
okay sure i'm a detective i get it hello
is someone there
hello
anyone going to jump out in
kill me
oh hi are you in timeout
we playing hide and seek right now
should i go run
okay all right you little scoundrel
try to come catch me if you can
hmm
how
peculiar
oh oh looks like the panel is completely
busted
i'm not getting this thing on anytime
soon
okay well oh damn it
always looking in the wrong places
stop wasting your time doing chores
and put those detective skills to work
remember
8
11
94
8 11
94
well probably august 11 1994
of which date some crime probably
occurred
oh
apparently my key works on this doorknob
this card that i had
to predict and serve okay
meeting room key connor to joey joey i
am currently unable to get into my
office i left behind my key card in the
building last night and it was no longer
where i placed it i am unsure as to
where it went or who touched it i had to
rely on kenny to unlock my office for me
maybe we can get something sorted out
real soon
well i mean i think i got the key card
before i would read that note i don't
know
was that always open was that always
open
i don't feel like that was open before
but then again i don't know if i look
down here too closely carla have you
checked the security systems lately i
saw that someone had tried accessing the
cameras last night and i wanted to make
sure it was you don't hesitate to ask me
if you need anything sincerely timothy
am i i'm emmett i'm none of these people
i can't open those
yeah this is probably open
i'm sorry did anybody else hear a
footstep
i wish i could zoom
i don't think there was anything in the
darkness
lexing you'd tell me if there's
something in the darkness right
okay cool thanks
well
i got a key to the meeting room i don't
know where the meeting room oh it's
probably that one
okay
anybody in here
speak now forever hold your peace
oh
wait what's in front of there
it's a mannequin
terrifying
kim it has come to my attention that
there have been multiple reports of
property tampering within the last week
alone with you often staying after were
after hours for your janitorial
janitorial work i wanted to first come
to you to ask about the situation please
do not hesitate to notify me of any
suspicious activity you find during your
shift
okay i think i see a key card there is
the same numbers that the man was
repeating earlier in a date format what
what what do you there's a key attached
to it how can you see that the man wants
me to remember some specific date or
some specific time
i don't know what i'm looking for
eight eleven ninety four five something
on it in the records room
in the records room you say
sure
which one's a records room
oh hey buddy how you doing oh where are
you going
you're cute you're cute no
all right
this is the records room
records room key okay this was not the
records room
okay
is this the records room
oh
bye
uh august 11th 1994 emmett thompson
neighbors complain of excess noise
coming from their next door apartment
home of the david birch and temporarily
his friends thomas and andrews both
inhabitants were stubborn to cooperate
it was an accident okay
[Music]
i see right through your little lies
emmett
that man
is like a brother to me
and you killed him
just for talking back to you
you're a mess in it
one that went unpunished for a long time
but now
that's gonna change huh
is it what what is
this i knew it would turn out this way
emmett
maybe things
would have been different
if you could just own up to your
mistakes
goodbye
i wish things could have been better
oh
did anyone get a bit of war stash or
look it was a mistake
i didn't mean to it was an accident i
swear okay not bad the only thing i
could say about it in terms of spook
factor was that it was dark and there
were some things lurking in the shadows
namely a man in a mask i think that you
could have set up a bit more guilt early
on about it if like because the story i
get what it is you know this guy's
seeking revenge against uh a cop that's
trying to like get work done late and
you know long time ago whatever i feel
like there could have been done a little
more but still not bad well made can't
complain
moving on
this is uploaded a horror game about
what i'm assuming is uploading videos as
a youtuber or a streamer of some sort
and there is horror involved in this
process
oh oh no i'm a minecraft youtuber
what fresh hell is this hell is empty
hell is empty all the devils are here
playing minecraft i got nothing against
minecraft
i got nothing
12 33.
2 2 22. what a coincidence that's the
day i'm recording this
weird
it seems like i've fallen asleep for a
long time
okay hey it's uh oh what's stringbean
it's uh uh flumpo uh what's his name um
oh man arm man big arm man huge arms big
teeth sharp teeth man flumpy flumpo i'm
thinking a flump some kind of a flump
flumpo flumpy
flimbo
flappers flapper no
flappy flappy bird flap
tin
flapson
the son of the flap flap
hug
huggy huggy woogie i got there
eventually guys don't worry about it i
wonder when the next chapter of that is
gonna come out percy to sit
uh
i don't need food or to go to bathroom
nah nah
a life is the grind get this [ __ ] done
um
okay
well that noise is a problem for the
quality of my audio playstation jump
scare compilation 2022
man my internet is slow if that's still
uploading
you to stand up okay why
warning why warning if you can't see
them they can't see what do you mean
what are you talking about what are you
talking about
what are you referring to
what do you mean
what do you mean
uh
oh no don't do that
who's there at my window
that's normal
this is fine
that's
not fine
um um
um
i should probably go back to sleep
that's what i'm beginning to think
is that i should go back to sleep
and i'm gonna do that
or i'm gonna sit down no i'm gonna go
hockey woogie flumpy flumbo
what happened to you
that's peculiar
um
man that's taking a while uh
people really want to see my playstation
jump scare compilation i'll go back to
sleep no maybe i will i'm gonna do that
i'm gonna go no
no
what is up on my
what is up there
hi welcome
you know i thought this was like a house
or something or an apartment at least
where there wouldn't be anyone trying to
jostle a mom
is that you
i'll go to
doesn't seem like anything's happening
here
go to bed someone turned out the lights
for me
yawn
[ __ ] being played in a horror game i
just wanna
oh wait no
oh come on
and he slept once more and then he died
legend says he's still sleeping to this
day well
don't
i ain't a coward right i'm not a coward
i am here
as a dedicated youtuber i did not know
that going to sleep would do that
i assumed that it would but that didn't
mean that i was gonna do anything
about it
about that but anyway let's try this
again shall we oh
statues
close eye i didn't know that since when
could i do that
all right fine so that's what it meant
by
can't see you can't see me can't see we
can't see us that's what it meant
i get it
hi
hi
why does it take so long to upload how
did i miss that dialogue before
how did i miss any of this also that
you've got the category wrong this isn't
it's not quite right it's supposed to be
in the gaming category and you've got it
set up in the how to and style category
the like point zero zero zero one
percent of people that use youtube that
browse the different categories are
gonna be really upset
hello
okay
oh i can still sit down
hi
who's there blink blank
okay so i know the whole thing about you
can't see me i can't see you and we
can't see each other
so i just need to close my eyes i'll
come back when it gets to where i was
there you are
mom
if that is your real name
have alternates busted into my house
any progress
nope
no progress
well there seems to be a whole lot of
nothing
going on
oh my god hi how are you doing good to
see you whoa
oh i'm awake what
the hell
was that
all right how's my i can't look up and
down now
that's great
i can only look left right
that's a little strange
um
but 68
category still wrong 69
nice very nice okay
oh i can't get up anymore
uh
well this problem
um oh i can spin threes
what i can't get up anymore
oh
oh what
oh
yeah
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i
i'm both mad
and impressed
somehow
you scared me with the game simply
ending
i don't know how you managed that but
you did
so i applaud you whoever you are
made in just three days all right well
actually i need to check out their other
stuff because apparently the stuff they
make is kind of nice in some way
mystically but very good check it out
link is in the description moving on
welcome to jimmy's halloween 1985
immortalized in its essence i didn't
know that i need to do experience 1985
in its essence but i'm about to and so
are you
ah
the sweet era of analog
oh
hello
television after several bloodbaths in
the city of johnsville 37 year old
robert alderson was shot dead by police
on tuesday morning the serial killer
broke into family's homes at night and
murdered them with a hammer while they
were still sleeping that's the end of
the johnsonville nightmare i'm going
shopping i'll be back in a few hours and
jeffrey take care of your brother
jeffrey jeffrey
wasn't the serial killer named jeffrey
what was the name of the serial killer
uh i see
mom can i go to louise halloween party
have you finished all your tasks i'm
almost finishing you can go when you
finish them and take your brother with
you why do i need to take this idiot
with me why do i need to take this idiot
with me
sorry
you can join i have to go just obey me
jeff is an [ __ ] i'm really excited
for halloween i'd better go down to the
basement to get my costume
jeff you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a goddamn [ __ ] jeff
i hate you
anyway what is that turd that's trash
mom asked jeff to clean the floor
and guess what he was a big ol [ __ ]
jeffrey's tasks unclog the toilet clean
the living room floor get rid of the
rodents in the basement clean the
bedroom wash the dishes
okay jeffrey you better get on that
better hurry up jeffrey
it's a weird house
why do i have stamina
i guess that's an answer to my question
very topical and timely thank you
okay
i'm gonna go to the basement i guess
you're an [ __ ] um
oh i can go in here
is there anyone in the shower
all right i'm just gonna go to the
basement that's what it's said to do so
that's what i'm gonna do the door is
locked jeff must have the key
jeff
hey okay listen i'm not gonna ask nicely
you gave me the key to the basement
immediately now hey jeff you know where
the basement key is
yeah mom gave me the house keys you can
unlock the basement i need to get my
costume i'm really busy right now but if
you want to do my tasks i think i can
unlock it looks like i don't have a
choice you
fine
oh i can only carry one
you're a douche
hate you hi okay hate you
all right bye
what else do i need to do
unclog the toilet
grey
okay
now technically speaking i don't have to
do the the one you have to do in the
basement because you got to unlock that
to do that
all right that was easy
see that was easy you clogged it you're
supposed to unclog it
hello
i'll be i'll be back with you
not done hello
hello jimmy
sorry
hello hello
that's weird mom went shopping
dad
the call must have been dropped yeah
sure
you okay did i get all the ones
clean the bedroom one oh my god
did you do the rest of them
i
oh god the plunger is this not clean in
here
i unclogged the turlet
you're a turlet oh god damn it
find your highness
okay done unlock it please
ready i finished all your tasks
ready brad be quick why why be quick
shut up
hey jeff you took care of those rats
right
jeff
jeff
you wouldn't lock me down here would you
it's empty
that's probably that's for the best
door's stuck it looks like some mice nod
on this box nothing interesting here
oh good
good good
you didn't lock the door did you
did you jeff
dude jeff
jeff the door is locked i gotta go now
brat stay there till i get back
let me out please i have to find a way
out of here
yeah i do uh
god this is my nightmare
when i was a kid my brother did lock me
our basement was like partially finished
but it had a back part that was
unfinished and he locked me back there
okay
wooden board seems to be nailed
maybe there's a hammer
old generator must not be working
nothing here
no hammer
a note i tried to kill all the rodents
but it was useless i nailed a wooden
board in the room without a door to
avoid rodents
all right fair enough i guess
um
but what do i do
[Music]
oh ha
okay
step one complete
hello
ah
good
february 1985 a resident of west grove
said she was outraged by the local
police the resident said that she often
finds dolls candles and symbols in the
forest and after the disappearance of
her dog she found him dead days later
the official closed the case with her
saying it was a coyote attack
[ __ ] senses are going off the charts
here i thought the wall wasn't moving
there i ended up losing the extra keys
while i was in the basement bringing the
stuff down to the basement i'll go
through the locksmith tomorrow and make
new ones
who
wrote that
searching nothing useful searching
nothing useful searching
nothing useful
okay found a key good
all done here then
time to go up and enjoy my freedom
at a halloween party
he does not fit this
oh
good
grades
great
great
great
great
why there was no glass down there what
happened
hello
hello
fine it's nothing
it's nothing
it's nothing
screwed yv
rusty i don't think it's useful you
don't know that it's rusty i don't think
it's useful i don't say that about
pliers seems to be something on the back
but it's too heavy to push
all right
could get some leverage we could rig up
a pulley system of some sort oh
i can open the dry why
why why would i what
improvised rope hey
i
those boy scout classes really came in
handy so i can rig up a pulley system of
some sort
all right then
cool
great i'm free now
okay
halloween party here i come
okay
that's new
oh
what sound is this seems to be coming
from the living room
you know what else is coming from the
living room
blood
blood is coming from the living room i
might just call the police
oh my god
[Music]
that was a lot of build up for one scare
there
but i appreciate it you know
if
if i were to give any suggestion is to
put even more like ambient sound and
weirdness happening through the initial
phase leading up to it but with like
nothing actually being there because
even that that like glass breaking was
throwing me off but i feel like if there
was more of that it would have built up
even more you know like weird articles
down in the basement weird things a drip
of blood randomly happening you know
like something going on there because it
was good but also just like at the end
it was just kind of like oh you're dead
now you know which is fine because it
scared me but
would love to get more you could make me
even more paranoid leading up to that
but still i like that no very fun very
good jimmy very good
jeffrey's still an [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you
can't say the
you
[Music]
you